hey guys it is the 3rd of September
today my name is Jess Whittle and you're
tuned in against Bucky first up YouTube
megastar PewDiePie has completely
removed the ability to comment on his
videos the guy who manages the most
subscribed YouTube channel in the world
now sitting at over 30 million
subscribers has said he doesn't see the
support he used to in the comments in a
recent vlog which was heavy on the word
bros he said I go to the comments and
it's mainly spam it's people self
advertising it's people who are trying
to provoke it's all this stuff that to
me doesn't mean anything I don't care
about it I don't want to see it it's
been bothering me for so long now
I've been trying to find solutions to it
and trying to find ways to make it
better and I'm just sick of it so I'm
going to turn the comments off forever
Petey pyres said he hopes his fans
understand and that he still came to
chat with subscribers on Twitter and
reddit
in use it isn't all that surprising the
new 3ds is going to be preached and
locked Nintendo have decided to continue
that policy of region locking onto the
new console which means only games
brought within the same country as the
hardware both digitally and physically
will work on the device this
announcement comes in the face of
Nintendo fans who want so keen on region
locking namely the 32,000 who signed a
petition asking the company to alter
their strict policy on the original 3d
at the last minute under handheld which
was region free was the Nintendo DSi XL
last up today the Xbox one is headed to
28 - more countries this month the move
is extending from a release in Chile and
Colombia on September 2 to a Russian
release on September 26 and encompasses
countries in Asia South America Africa
and Europe soon after those 28 countries
get their hands on the console and
Microsoft have said they also intends to
bring Xbox one to Argentina Microsoft
have intentionally coincided to consult
availability in these new regions with
the release dates of big games like
destiny and FIFA 15 ask me a question of
the day let me know down in that comment
section what you think of region-locked
consoles if it's more news you're after
you can head to
site where we've got stories on
Assassin's Creed unity and Red Dead
Redemption that is it for me today
thanks for sticking around as usual and
I will see you same time tomorrow